but I feel like the the the Common
Thread with maybe marriage and sketch
comedy is commitment like you got to
have commitment for both right you do
you really do yeah I mean you isn't that
the key I mean I've never been a sketch
player you are the genius to my view
genius sketch player of all time I mean
you seriously I'm not just saying NE
you're here I've always believed that
when you insulted me I believe that
you're a genius at what you do but it is
about commitment right you always commit
one billion percent to the character
there's never any doubt you're in it all
the way yeah yeah I but to me it's
always to me sketch performing it's just
acting I I try to act as seriously
within the sketch as Merill Street would
in any drama right you know because the
thing is that what you want to be a mile
deep in the commitment not only not only
of you to the character but the
character to the situation they find
themselves in and that's always been
important to me is that I wanted to make
sure that I'm playing it as deep as
possible so that because it's not about
me winking or laughing it's about you
guys laughing and it's about giving as
much commitment to the to the project as
possible so and I feel like ke and
Peele I mean I I'm watching Kean Peele
now again because it's I just put it on
Netflix I mean I always watch them when
they've G the first time probably
watched it twice so probably watching it
the third time now um stands the test of
time which is not something you can say
about a lot of Comedy I mean I going
through your book I mean you give you
know a lot of props to people but I must
say like when you watch old shows they
humor is not like music people want to
hear the music from 50 years ago you
watch a sketch from 50 years ago doesn't
stand up it it rarely does rely your
does yeah it's still exactly it
really does it's amazing but like things
change like I feel like you guys you
know you give great props to Cal
Bernette which right in this building
where that show was done okay Saturday
Night Live and Carol Bernett kind of
overlapped as sketch shows right but
very different car brunette they were
like always cracking each other up right
Harvey Corbin and Tim con they couldn't
get through the sketch without laughing
at what they were doing yeah s live was
like that's
corny that's right we don't do that
anymore and they never did and that just
shows things change so when you watch a
Carol that sketch it does look a little
Museum mhm interesting interesting I
think I can feel I can feel harobi
corman's ghost over my
[Applause]
shoulder